les Ukrainiens l'appellent le train de
la victoire
une semaine après le départ des forces
russes le premier symbole de la vie qui
reprend à Kerson sous les acclamations
à son bord 200 passagers party hier soir
de Kiev
sur le quai vetlana en larmes se
précipite à la rencontre de sa petite
fille étudiante elle ne se sont pas vus
depuis le début de la guerre
en ce moment elle a vécu sous
l'Occupation elle a été très courageuse
je t'aime ma chérie
le quai de la gare se remplit de larmes
de joie après des mois de séparation
l'émotion de ce père qui avait préféré
envoyer ses enfants en sécurité dans la
capitale
c'est la première chose que j'ai dit à
ma fille je t'aime
je n'ai pas pleuré depuis très longtemps
et voilà ça y est je pleure quand je la
vois
personne est encore privé d'électricité
et d'eau les détonations continuent de
raisonner
mais ce matin les habitants ne veulent
entendre que la petite musique de la
liberté retrouvée
un expect on s'y attendait plus on est
si heureux c'est le plus beau jour de ma
vie
on rentre chez nous
je ne me suis pas senti aussi bien
depuis les neuf derniers mois
et l'Ukraine ne compte pas s'arrêter à
ce symbole les autorités viennent de
mettre en vente les billets pour un
prochain train entre Kiev la capitale et
Sébastopol en crime est toujours occupé
par les Russes manière de signifier que
les forces ukrainiennes comptent bien
reconquérir l'intégralité de leur
territoire